back to that incentive truth principle
so what's happening outside which means
me and I needs to be happening inside as
well so when he pushes I am NOT going
Yong Yong inside too I don't have the
mind of throwing young please go so I
just really relaxed everything is
relaxed
and I met zero I'm gonna call it a zero
meaning I'm not on the young side and
I'm not on the inside okay and that will
happen in the in the entire technique so
as you can see if I go plus then you can
see that I have this Center while I'm at
zero I'm not not in his center I have
I'm right there on the surface of his
Center so you can't control you can't
control him you see as I'm bowing it's
making my hand travel forward in the
sagittal plane okay and then whole
technique is like that so inside relaxed
if I start to move over here you can
still have this Center you see
I still have hey as as I come up I still
have this scent still have it come up I
still have it still happened and that's
what I did it take me so it looks like
it's all very Hin you see my dad totally
feels it differently because I don't
have this okay but it can't be I don't
want to push by how he's demonstrated
yeah it's it's all at that neutral so we
we do it the other way so he he tries to
go to us and if I stop here you can see
that he can't go past that I was in the
negative side he pushed through so I'm
doing the technique he can't compromise
that same thing as I come here and he
pushes he can't compromise that as I
trade push it you can't compromise so
I'm not negative I'm not plus I do this
same tip the same technique same exact
way so you know let's do it as a spot
test let's starts do the positives spot
test you see so I'll check here right
I'll check here I'll check here I'll
check here
they would do the negative check so he's
trying to push and push he's trying to
push push
he's trying to push I can't push my
English you can't push he's trying to
push you can't push and do you
understand does it who can understand
the to test
okay let's what we're going to try to do
is give us more metrics so you can see
if we're doing so
okay seven he'll feel around as I'm
doing the tech mush you see how it's
it's mushy okay
then come to the front though and he's
pushing here and just feel it's mushy
right okay but you can push you see and
I'm doing that so mushy mushy but stable
okay so as I go to the technique is
still mushy but it's stable
okay I'm over here on you and you must
do the negative test so he's pushing on
me but mushy but stable
okay I go as I stand up you're still
there right still mushy because it's
easy to go like this you come around and
you feel around right okay everything is
super intense you're trying to do this
stuff
so I have positional integrity but I and
I have sent a connection but nothing is
is tensed okay we'll have we'll go in
threes and your person will third person
is gonna come around and feel a few
they're doing it and press test on
something that's you things not exactly
like the other side of your body do you
get that because what what I'm seeing is
as you go like you right now this arm is
totally not doing it and you now it'll
start again do you see that so you're
gonna do both third person let's see
what's tense and then press check that
other part that they think is not in it
at any point so let's say when my when
my arm this is where I see a lot and so
he he's pushing the he's pushing on me
right so if I let called that energy you
can see he's trying to knock me down can
you try to knock me down okay that's
fine
and when you guys break this arm this
arm is like nah you're not doing it
inside so if you come around and you
have like a wrist grab yeah you see and
if she's pushing you can't you wouldn't
be able to hit that arm lift
do you understand but as I'm going to be
using I mean do you guys have parts of
your body that's not working and as a
result you aren't actually doing young
beyond because internally you don't have
the yen in the Yong record side you see
that and so because you're doing you're
doing young too young by default of the
other hand being way to him then this
time we go wait on that's how you're
doing the technique but as you can see
if you can't stop that half the movie in
the same way that he can't make that
mark go back okay it's gonna be a
relaxed reconcile getting young
externally internally as well okay so
the first third person press check on
those things you should be able to see
where yeah that's totally not like the
other arm you should see the difference
that silly
as a purpose so I have to orient it
towards an aim I can't either
I'm not just trying to develop it in
myself okay I do need to do that but I
want to have a purpose to it in this
okay and the one that is now a living
you is that you you don't have the
center connection your you're not sure
how to get it it's really easy and
different you get themselves have a
different skill level of connecting
their Center into their arm so for
example if I have a bouquet who is doing
the in pressure testing right from their
Center
I will automatically by default find
their Center simply by staying connected
to the risk as they put their Center
into that but as it as you have
different you get so that became who's
like pushing only at the shoulder I have
to still be able to find a center and
that becomes a more of a task where even
decent okay who can do it here will now
start preserving themselves and
withdrawing from the prescribed energy
that Luca is assigned to so there there
are their centers not in there are many
more do you see that so you can't just
push on the arm it'll do that you have
to be able to still find the center to
see how I'm doing that and the same
thing goes especially here like if I
just push on his arm to arm will
collapse so even as the arm is collapsed
and I still have to find the center and
this is where most
that still have a reference out of fear
they take completely out of their
harmony yeah and so you're throwing and
you don't have near Ohio Center so it
doesn't change it's just in other words
it doesn't change he's got his Center in
his arm is just that was easier because
he put it he put it there okay but the
sensation is the same so I keep feeling
for the sensation as I'm doing this keep
feeling for it doesn't matter whether I
I have to push to do it I have to push
to do it or even if I go is to here so
let's let's pay attention to that
you should feel it'll go totally totally
hit on okay so like you come here and
you disconnects you're like oh holy cow
that just feels like a wet you okay that
went noodle that transition is in in a
combative application that's the
beginning of the calendar and the
beginning of their day neutralizing your
control over the center so you want to
know what that feels like and you would
not do the technique that they just
counter do you get it so as as you're
going you would feel that I still have
this Center I still have wanna have that
skill so I don't want you to
subconsciously go and you're being ruled
by keyboard that's this is not keen on
this is the shake but it's not cool
mother okay so always task yourself with
I have this sense
I never met it goes then and so
compatibly if we go he goes limp
I suppose keep the center if I can't
keep the center at that point then I
would catch it at another point it's not
so I have to have this same eun-jung
reconciliation externally internally
because it allows me to have sensitivity
enough and control enough to be able to
know - I have Center control or not and
this this is what what I'm trying to say
is this is a good training tool - not
him put his Center in his grip and it
opens the door for me to feel what I'm
kind of feel for and he's not wasting
50% of his mat time because he is
learning how to utilize the center at
his extremities do you get that which is
usually how we're fighting we're not
fighting like
okay so I want to know how to project my
Center away from my spine in this - a
compass so he's he's learning that -
which is why I say that okay who is who
has made themselves more projectable is
that route game who's more able to
project someone okay but in real life
because the connected center because
being centered is ultimately related to
your degree of reconciled fear those who
cannot use their Center particularly or
remain center particularly in human
versus human violence even abstract
versions like p1 Wazza right will not
have reconcile fear damages to my
presenter okay so they'll be from their
point of view
wasting 50% of their map time but they
provide an interesting next level
training for me because he put his
Center in his group and all I have to do
is maintain my position and I should
have this Center as he put it there but
that unreconciled fear could get doesn't
do that and now it raises the next level
of aim of my agenda what I want to do is
can I can I find his Center from
wherever I'm touching him do you get
that okay so he's loose I have to be
able to find his Center
wherever I'm touching him and and with
whatever I'm touched
okay all right so now this raises the
question that that who can you'll feel
the lip do as if you fell okay
why do I say it's a nice level skill is
because I am the active agent in the
center connection as not yet not okay
okay so he goes I feel that go loop but
look I pick up his Center you see I'm
not relying on him so his arm goes weak
and usually we see all that all day
that's what happens but you find the the
relationships that you need to get his
center would be together and you I can't
tell you what it is go back and ten
degrees at 0.25 km/h it's a sensation
and it's the same one that you should be
feeling here it that you should maintain
here that you maintain here to see that
and so when he goes off when he goes
limp you still have it what so we're on
wherever I'm not it's dead I'm not doing
this
you see wherever I'm at I maintain this
connection okay even when it goes to the
pin I'm not going like this right I am
maintaining that's
that's moving in so your question is a
false question because you sing that you
lost that connection was gone
yes it was gone but it's not gone
because of what they did is gone because
you didn't move to the next and then to
the point and connection back then what
I'm asking you to do is to feel when it
goes limp and find the ones on the next
pop to keep the sensation all of that
that is the bare minimum of g1 plus all
the mechanical and tactical concepts
that you're supposed to have so if you
leave any of it up so I do I'm doing
Keelung and I just keep doing it I'm
working on the extension and the
connection and when when you see the
attendees okay and I'm just working that
trying to be relaxed
still very